μας ευχαριστεί γιατί και ο πάρα όλιπια πάρα όλιμπισμός είναι ένα πιλονας αθηλητασμούςμο το οποίο
όπως λέμε δικδικαίωμαν ή συ συμμετοχής των αθλισμό για όλους αυτό γίνεται και σεπ και
στην πράξη πως γεννήθηκε αυτή δέα ισκέψη να πάμε να διεκδικήσουμε το ευρο πάσκε του
κ δε είναι είναι δέα του κορνοιού όταν θυμάστε κανιά ίκοκσιάν αν είμασταν σταστον στο
ζούσαμε όλοι όλοι όλος ο κόσμος όλος ο πλανή της των κορώνοιών και εμείς εκεί
στην ομοσπονδία να επισ να αναφέρω ότι αναλάβαμε μαζί με τους συνοργάτεςμους στο δεκαοκτό άρα
πολύ νωρίς ανατραπήκαν κάποια πλάνα που είχαμε νι υπόψη μας μια μέραν όπως συζητούσαμε μαζί
με των γενικώ διευθυνδης όμος πουνδια των άθουν των αντοδίυτί τ τι υνέργες θα κάναμε
για να διατηρήσουμε των κόσμο του πάσκεέτσι ενεργό με διάφορα διαδεκτίακά είτε σε μινάρια είτε
εγυμναστικές και διάφορα άλλα μουλέει στη μουλές την πορεία τη συζήτης εκείνο εκείνων τον προείνο
μάθος ότι ξέρεις επιδίο αθο συμμετέχεικα στν στην εκτελεστική επιτροπή της ευρωπακιςσομός ποα μο λέ
ξέρεις δυσκολεύο μαστε να βρούμε χώρες να φίλο ξεενήσουμε των βρο πς και τι γυναικών
που τότε θέταν δύο ιχωρές και του λέο φαντάστου η δυσκολία που θα προκύψει για
το ευρωπάς και των αντρών λόγο και της περισότερης δυσκολίας αλλά κυρίως τουτης οικονομικής έτσι
ότι είναι πιο ακριβώ να στο πιο ακριπήδιο οργανωσία πό ότη είναι το ευρομα κετ
μου λέει ναι να δούμε πόότε θα ξεκινήσει και θα ανοίξει αυτή διαδικασία και επάνω
στην πλάγαν έτσι το είχα πάρει εγώ μου λέο αθος να διαφερτούμε και του λωεγώ
βλέπουμε ταν η πρώτηφορά που ενδιάφερτηκε χώράμα ναι για τέτοια διοργάνως ναιναι εμείς τότε είχαμε
στο μυαλό μας το πως θατο πως